each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
hello everybody Oh today I am going to
talk about software born a mechanism for
device pass through and sharing this is
the joint work with sort of himself so a
current network processing techniques
has higher overhead particularly for the
virtual machines and and the network
processing in the case requires special
devices like sr every device and stay
with the sorry device there are some
limitations such that that the engaged
communication is is not not very high
performing we trying to solve this
performance one with only software only
mechanism so we don't need any special
devices and using our technique case can
directly talk to each other we provide
in case switching and we we are also
secured ll against any malicious guest
in the rest of my talk I want to explain
what this SI we devise sh and how we are
doing these things so often we run
several applications on on our machine
or all these applications here the same
system resources since for example all
these applications here you are the same
network device but since this
applications are untrusted we run them
in lower driblets mode and we we put a
piece of software in high privilege mode
which with cell which directly talks to
the device and shared is this device to
these applications so when when we learn
a simple socket UDP benchmark on a 10
gbps network card we found at it it is
very slow so we achieve around one by 31
21 x 33 x of through a maximum
achievable throughput with 60 bite of
packets and with 1500 bytes of packets
we get around 1 by 4 to 1 by 5 x road on
the reason of why sista byte packets
performs very
as compared to 1500 by package listen
dis and how device driver so device has
a circular queue which has 512 slots and
when we send these packets we puts these
packets inside the queue notice the CPU
overhead is per packet whereas the
device throughput is measured in terms
of bytes hence the smaller packets
stresses the cpu more than the larger
packets here is a work which profiles
the network network stack and found
there are several pieces which are
responsible for this throughput
degradation and they come up with a
bunch of optimizations but the main
optimizations where that they create
user ring which is similar to the
hardware ring and they share this ring
with the colonel in some
producer-consumer manner so this is the
net map user ring which is initially
failure yeah so we are running a network
benchmark which is simple you d which is
simple sending UDP packets for the small
packet so if you're sending around I
mean it's / 32 whatever yeah but for
larger packet to you you achieve around
3gbps of trooper yeah on Signal Corps
romantic powerful I mean only one if one
process is sending a packet then does
not matter how many cool
so so network-based a bunch of optima
isn't one of those yep night so how is
this user ring which is shared with the
Condamine user producer-consumer manner
so they failed this year ranging from
32x 465 packets 4.5 x for bigger pockets
all that is happening because because of
the user and Colonel interface so when
user sends the packets Colonel copies
the packets into its memory and then
then process the packet through the wire
so they are and and since this memory
can be swept or swappable so the pages
get swept all the time so in order to
prevent that they have to allocate and
filling memory again and again and so so
net map creates a large chunk of memory
which is unsolvable and then share this
unstoppable memory with the user process
now now user can directly put packets
inside that unsuitable memory and and
when then then the device driver can
directly put pointers inside the hard
wearing because now there is no no
problem of swapping the memory and they
are sending packet in batches so so they
they create the user in which is similar
to the hard wearing they filled the user
in with the packets and then device
driver puts all these packets inside the
hardware ring and and so this is the
network work it is evaluated on on Linux
so they need map
yeah but this work is evaluated on Linux
this net maple this is not my work so I
am so let's consider a scenario where
instead of running these applications we
want to run an entire operating system
on our system so notice now now we can
allow the guest operating we call this
operating system as case to operating
system and our hosting system is a
system is called host operating system
so we can't allow guest operating system
device driver to directly access your
your devices so what we do that when the
guest operating system tries to send the
packets we take a trap inside the host
OS and then host OS emulates the
behavior of the of the device in such a
way that the guestlist feels that you
just take it talking to the real device
since the software stack plays a
critical role in in overall throughput
this trap and emulate we have your leads
to severe performance bernard is the
reason why we need to do this trap and
emulate because we want to run untrusted
guess to us if the modifications are
allowed we can do much better so for
example instead of taking this trap we
can create another process which is
running on some other core and we we can
create a shared cube between our guest
driver and this this process so when the
guests needs to send some packets is
puts those packets inside the shared Q
and do some other work meanwhile the the
other process which is running on some
other code will process these packets
and once the processing done it notifies
the waste driver soon so even if we run
this network framework inside the or
para terrible shot guest we found that
it performs very bad and and since it
requires an extra code for four cycle
emulation on uni processor setting it
it's performs very well so so here is
another work which which further
optimize this power
interface by by doing the similar kind
of optimizations that the net map does
so it profiles the guest and host
networking stack and then then did some
optimization like memory p a location
batching and eliminating copies and they
achieve very good performance so so the
reason why we need to do this para
virtual why we need to use para ver
sorre drive our tribe or emulate because
there is only one hardware ring and it
has to say it among all the guest OS and
the host OS so hardware comes hardware
vendor comes with this special devices
which has multiple queues now you can
assign one queue is to its guest OS and
now the guests can directly write to to
those devices and since there is no
setting between these cues there is no
security issues so we can achieve bare
metal performance landed performance
using sr of every devices but but these
devices come with some drawbacks because
they have limited number of cues so now
you can support only as many gates as
the number of queues inside those
devices this devices are hard to migrate
they they need extra TV is they need
extra hardware support and and even with
the small number of guests if if this
gets tries to communicate with each
other they are limited by the hardware
device bandwidth and and I i will so
next that that this problem occurs in in
network function virtualization so
hardware middleboxes are very common
these days so widely hardware media
boxes are far worse proxies and talk but
there are drawbacks of this Hardware
middleboxes because they are inflexible
and so if you want to add some feature
to the hardware middle box it is very
hard they are power hanging a
power-hungry they are expensive in terms
of money and they are difficult to
manage often it requires a specialized
person to manage this boxes
so current trend is towards network
function virtualization where we we run
these this this devices as a software
inside of inside a virtual machine
running on on on commodity hardware and
so so often some packets needs to be
processed by several middleboxes so
often these middleboxes needs to
communicate with each other so if you
use sr every devices and one middle box
needs to communicate with other middle
box it is limited by the device
bandwidth and in the whole scenario
sometimes when i guess send the package
to another guess it goes through the
external switch and then go back to the
guest so so another work which we net
beam which which found that if they use
10gbps as our every device they found of
only 5 gbps of throughput when they use
l3l three router as your media box
another possible scenario is you can
create a virtual switch so now you don't
need to send if the guest needs to send
package to each other they can send
through a virtual sis they don't have to
send through through the external device
but but but but now the host has to
intervene in every communication between
this metal box it's so so this is very
slow in our using our system you can run
this virtual switch directly inside the
case so now you can run software
switches inside the gas and the guests
can communicate with each other directly
without any host in tourism another
example is fire well so so so firewall
are centralized systems so the only
place you can put this file is outside
your hosting system because all all all
the package needs needs to be processed
through this far away but but in our
technique you can run these firewalls
inside the way stretch them so you don't
need extraordinary
so this is a yeah yeah so so so we in
our technique we we directly expose the
network card directly to the case in
safe and secure manner so I by secure I
mean that that even if the gateways can
directly access the network device which
is also shared with the host it can do
not do any damage and we don't require
any SRO we support SiO device or
hardware support and and we also allow
increase switching and we are also
secure against malicious case so this is
some results from this work so so we
found line dead performance even with
sista vector packets so so you don't
need a specialist are you a device that
there is no different queues for each
case the hardware doesn't provide any
sense of any such thing yeah so each
guest will access the hardware directly
as though he force it directly oh yeah
so can we do to be why would the 11
guess not be able to overwrite one under
the case this time yes so isolation all
guys so so so in our case the bush in
starter a parish or driver inside the
guests and it can ensure that the guests
cannot invert interfere with the
operation of that driver so it yeah
driver is inserted by the host now that
driver is tres a and and it the host can
ensure that this is a run in some sand
box so it is sandbox from rest of the
guests stress
sign the guest yeah and somehow the
guests should not be be covered yeah so
we achieve around a vhe blind who's we
we achieve landed performance even with
the 60 bite of packets which is a
thirty-seven percent improvement over
clicquot is for send and one hundred
sixteen percent for receive our
technique is para wats also we require
guess I drivers which we call fast our
driver and we establish a trust between
driver and the horse twist so um so in
our taking the hostess insert a trusted
device driver which we called fossa a
driver in the case at a space and and
once the driver is get loaded it it
marks all the code bases of the driver
as read-only says that the the guest OS
cannot change the code of the of the
driver and then it computes the
cryptography has from the guest driver
code pages to verify the integrity of
the driver we don't trust the case toys
in any manner and we we assume that the
guest OS can change any memory location
and can execute any arbitrary code okay
so so the weight of a guess
no we the hosts insult of trusted driver
inside the gates address space and and
interest its own driver but it don't
trust the other and other part of the
list oh yeah yeah driver cottage we are
just yeah so the way way your driver
access the network devices network
devices the memory map device so so some
part of the physical addresses basis
tooted as the device device memory and
if you map those pages inside your page
table you can directly talk to the
device so we map map the device pages in
the extended page table of the cases
then now now guests and directly talk to
the device by adding those pages inside
its page table so we create a privilege
page table where we map all the revised
spaces and and and our fossil driver has
only one entry and exit point during the
interview we load the people's page
table and during the exit we load the
previous previous page table such that
now now now the the the privileged
vegetable is only operation only the
time when when the first our driver is
running and but but but the the
malicious gates can can add device
spaces into its own base table or it can
create a new vegetable address the
device faces into it and load this page
table so we configure our hardware to
take trap on all the instructions that
can potentially change the guest virtual
address space let our move to see a
theory move to see our for and move to
cr0 more pc 03 is used to load a new
page table and move to see our forum to
say 0 using that you can change paging
more disabled paging etcetera and and to
protect against guests to add a device
pages inside the page table we write
protect the case vegetable so when the
guests tries to write in any anything
into its page table there is a trap in
the host and then hosts can emulate
those changes but notice i said that
that we need to load this privilege page
table inside out faster driver so at the
beginning we need
to load the faster for this privilege
vegetable and doing the exit we need to
load the in his original page table
there will be two traps inside our first
half driver if we configure our hardware
to take trap on move to see or three
instruction so we need to do something
else in order to save those straps so
this is our technique which we call this
is a new technique proposed by us which
is dynamic binding of code subtraction
so notice a guest OS can execute any
instruction if that instruction exists
in the in the address space of the guest
OS so if you can remove all the outputs
corresponding to move to see our three
instruction from the gas address space
guests cannot execute those instruction
so so we use extended page table to mark
all the guests pages as none executable
at the beginning so the guests cannot
execute any instruction in the beginning
and when the guests tries to execute any
instruction there we were trapped inside
the horse then host can scan the page of
which the guess is trying to execute and
if it founds move to CL 3 or code on
that page then it it replaces that
awkward with in three instruction in
Teresa special instruction which is used
by by software the debuggers to put put
breakpoint we configure our our guest we
configure obvious choice to take it take
trap on in three or instruction so so
there is a problem that this this move
to see Arthur output could be a part of
a could be a middle middle of an
instruction for example if you see the
first move instruction it it contains
move to see our three opcode and if we
replace it by in three instruction now
the instruction get gets changed so
there will be no trap inside the host
and said the case we have here will be
changed so to deal with this problem we
identify the correct instruction
boundary and pass the instruction from
from the beginning so let's see how its
work so for example this this is the
guest code page and initially the gist
in trying to execute this instruction at
pc 4 so there will be fault inside the
host now now the host who host keep this
information with every pace that that
what is the instruction boundary it
knows on that pace because because hoes
because the guest doesn't know what what
are the actual based bound is so it adds
it gives this metadata sin so it updates
this known in Section bondage at pc 4
and now it scanned the page and it forms
that at pc three there is this move to
co 3 or code but it doesn't know the
correct in section boundary so it it it
it executes this page in trap and
emulate manner let's after sometime it
found a fault on pc one now it knows a
valid instruction boundary before pc
three so it disassembled from pc one and
it found that the pc to at pc to there
is instruction which contains the smooth
ER 300 quote so now it can pass the
whole instruction with with entry
instruction and now and now it can
retain the execute permission or on that
pace so now guess one can directly
execute that phase so we run a speck in
benchmark and a forked benchmark to
evaluate the overheads of of our divorce
technique so so for pity's of benchmark
which creates around 40,000 processes in
a loop so since there are too many
processes there is lot of paging
activities and lot of settling
activities and so we we found around 18
x overhead of divorce in case of for
quit but for for middleboxes only one
process is running inside the guest OS
and there shouldn't be any too much
demand paging and and and settling so
there is no overhead of duboce when we
when we use for our network applications
so this this is a hour faster pseudo
code corresponding to our faster driver
so there is only one entry and exit
point to the first our driver
and you can see at line 5 we are we are
loading the privilege space table and
and and at 13 we are loading the old
vegetable so notice this instruction
which which which lowers the octopus
vegetable is move extr three so it it
moves the contents in the CRX resistance
inside the CR three so now Melissa's
gifts can can this load any arbitrary
page table inside the ax register and
can directly jump to this instruction
and it can access the device pages
fortunately there is a support is a
hardware support which which allows host
ways to configure guest OS to take trap
on on every cr3 instruction except it
can maintain a cast of four values on
which it wouldn't take in trap if you
move if you execute move to say orange
section so we add our our previous page
table in value inside that cast and and
other three values can be used for the
applications which are which is calling
this first our driver your number of
applications that that can a usual not
limit I mean so so if you use more than
three application there will be trapped
because if all the applications would
have different page tables so for three
applications we have a space is space in
the cash but more than three
applications inside a virtual machine
but but if you see the current
virtualization trend the trend is
towards lightweight virtual machines
where we run only one application inside
the histories so in in that scenario all
the demand paging and and sitting is the
part of the host OS so in the end in
that case there wouldn't be any overhead
yeah that is stories now so we are
running the net map thing inside the
gauge to this so whatever then in net
map the stack it is inside the cage to
us now guys choice doesn't need to take
any trap so on the transmitted power 3
plus our own net matter using any any
application plus own net map link to
hardware thing and only see path it
reads the hard wearing and nq's the
package through the respective case to
provide mutual exclusion among this
guest OS faster drivers we use a state
law through pure bliss vegetable and we
also do 20 copy on both transmit and
receive side so receive side 0 copy has
a potential for Miss message so we need
to copy packets when there is a mismatch
also the receive side 0 copy has a
potential for man-in-the-middle attack
so we saw our results with and without
receives side 0 copy so so we found no
overhead when we found line net
performance when we are running only one
guest VM but but with four guest OS on
system 60 byte packets received we found
a throughput degradation of around
thirty seven percent we also implement a
in guests off versus so now suppose to
guess needs to communicate to each other
it don't really have to do through the
network device so you can do it in
software so here we don't have to limit
we are not limited by the device
bandwidth and we found a very good
throughput with with this several
combination of sander and and receivers
so to conclude we huge dynamic binary
awkward subsection for improving our
virtualization performance we achieve
near perimeter performance which is up
to 2x faster than best known para
versatile solution and we
also do n guess searching questions this
is still a work in progress
he also so para ver sorre driver or so
anywhere in the current scenario also
there are different drivers for for the
windows and linux and all the operating
right not or even if in the gauge to a
scale services windows right some
guesses or windows some case of Elden up
so there are different drivers inside
those thing yeah so yeah in order we
make in order to support different case
we need to make them compatible with
each other so I think we only need to
change the interface I mean so the so
somebody is calling that that gash
driver right so if we just use the same
calling convention in different guest OS
I think we can we can suppose but but
anyway you need to write you need to
understand what is the existing
interface between the between the driver
and and the rest of the voice and you
need to write or drive in such yo
yeah week yeah I think we can support
all the functionality that that the VMA
virtual States supports but but their
virtual virtual switch is work inside
the host of V we can do a bit higher
yeah yeah yeah so I still need to
investigate that what what kind of
functionality that the vicious supports
but but I am sure that whatever you can
do inside the host you can also do
inside the size of whatever the host
driver can do the gas driver can do the
same same thing
Oh
how what all attacks do you prevent you
know is it like bulletproof or can I do
something you sure the above techniques
like the boss and so on if I'm clever
can i sir commend all of those things
and compromises I really so me we are
not able to think about any any such
kind of attacks but yeah but but we
don't have any formal proof that that
our odd thing is correct
I think we can also so even if this
Hardware has multiple cues they have
limited number of kills right so they're
fixed number of kills so we can make
make the cues more scalable so 1q could
could be saved in all among multiple
guess that that we can also support so
in that way we can improve the
scalability of the existing hardware
support
yeah so it's within the hardware right
so we are putting the device driver and
said yeah yeah only only the driver
which are we are putting inside so we
can insert the mutual exclusion right oh
yeah yeah yeah so we are using a said
even if this when you're talking through
the device right so you do some mio the
my is going anyway anyway going to be
very slow so when you talk to the device
it is really slow so even if on your
system if your your device driver is
when your device why we're talking to
your or your device it does in some
mutual exclusion so even if your lot of
course so only one core is directly
talking to the device at at one time and
this is our every device as multiple Q
so they can do in parallel so on
different caves different drivers can
talk to the different cues yeah but but
if you want to say or 1q among the the
different gauge story you have to do in
in some mutual exclusion
so they are all right already paradise I
mean for Q and ya know in our case there
is only one Q then there are no 4 q's
there is no a special device so there is
only one Q and all the guests are
setting the same if they're 8 q's in sr
IV devices and there are then then they
can just use one Q it's right so yeah so
so 1 q could be shared among among the
one sr I awake you could be same shared
among the multiple gays but but you need
to do it in some mutual exclusion